thank you very much Anna and I'm pleased
to say I'm joined now by the defense
secretary Ben Wallace thank you very
much for being with us uh on this day
appreciate your time and if you just
cast your mind back a year and when you
first heard that Russian forces had
crossed the border when you were hearing
that explosions had taken place in this
capital city what was going through your
mind
well I think the first thing was uh you
know I got in touch with my counterpart
to see that he was all right and I think
the first thing is you know is is
everyone all right and uh you know it
was very important for me I'd been to
visit Ukraine a number of times both the
security minister and defense secretary
and you know I know people out there and
I was obviously very concerned I was
also sort of filled with a bit of
sadness because despite International
efforts you know both adversary and
friend had done their very best to try
and persuade Russia not to follow this
foolish cause they were just determined
to press on and then lastly I remember
going into the office and saying very
early on you know early in the morning
we have to give Ukraine hope we have to
show the world and we have to show them
in you know in Ukraine and the media we
have to show that Russia is not
infallible that in fact that it can fail
at this and if there is any any Media or
stories that demonstrate like your own
reporting and other reporters you know
of the thing that show Russia is not
having a success we must to make sure
that people know that far and wide
because it's the hope that has driven
these Brave ukrainians to doing what
they're doing and it's the hope that I
think helped gel the International
Community beyond the initial sort of
horror of the invasion
so let's look ahead then Boris Johnson
told me yesterday that the UK should in
his words break the ice and send Jets to
Ukraine are we going to do that
no we're not going to send our own
typhoon jets in the in the short term to
Ukraine we've been quite clear about
that and you know I I think you know I
the one thing I've learned in this
conflict is you probably have as well
Marcus you can't rule anything in and
Rule anything out but but I've also
watched uh you know embryonic uh sort of
military aid start with handheld
anti-tank missiles that Britain was the
first in Europe to give before the
conflict growing to now gifting you know
over nearly 200 Western tanks and
helicopters have gone in in huge amounts
of equipment from the International
Community so I watched it grow that the
key thing here is it's not a sort of ad
hoc plan it's often in response to the
needs on the ground of the ukrainians
but also it's about a realism you know
we we have designed our forces to fight
in a NATO way and that is not the
original design that the ukrainians
inherited when they broke away from the
Soviet Union so so what we have to do is
make sure that when we gift anything
that in some cases we gift the training
and the cape abilities alongside it so
for example gifting a fighter jet Mark
comes with hundreds of people raw you
know Engineers Pilots training
electronic warfare then you know the
more complicated the platforms the
greater the tale and you know the West
is not going to be putting troops into
Ukraine uh in in those scales you know
the idea that you know we would put
typhoon in you'd have to send 200 RAF
people and we're not going to do that
we've said that quite clearly in this
current stage but what we have offered
is that if a country wants to gift a
Russian or a Soviet a model like a
MiG-29 and there are some countries in
in NATO who have them then Britain will
do its very best to either backfill with
our own Jets or indeed provide some form
of air policing to cover that their loss
of vulnerability and a capability I
think that's quite important message
that's what the US did in Poland I think
with tanks he polls donated over 200
272s and they were backfilled by
American Abrahams that is one of the
methods we've been using over the last
year
okay so that you're pretty clear no
typhoons in the near term
um what do you make of Deborah haynes's
reporting yesterday that UK weapons and
ammunition stores are Solo that it risks
not being able to support Ukraine or
keep Britain safe
um how short are we of weapons and
ammunition well first of all very few
countries openly talk about their scale
of stockpiles because to do so would to
leave them vulnerable uh to the enemy
knowing what you have in your bunkers
effectively but look it's not a new uh
observation that this Ukraine war and
the way Russia was fighting has shown
across the West that our stockpiles over
the last three decades have often born
the brunt of Defense cups or indeed you
know the hollowing act that you've heard
me talk and we have to restock those now
Britain has early on already started
restocking them again what it's also
exposed is that if you think for example
the end laws the anti-tank missiles that
we put in in last January Britain into
Ukraine uh you know we've been placing
orders for these things we've been
buying them in their thousands and once
that orders fulfilled the supply Chain's
gone and done something else and so you
don't you don't just sort of switch a
button you have to reheat that supply
chain and that's been a challenge across
the board but we are fixing it our stock
though are you worried about our stock
I'm not worried about our stock for two
reasons one is we've now started to
place orders to replenish them and where
we haven't placed orders we've started
the work to make sure we have the supply
chain or find alternative sources and
I've already been uh receiving now some
some more in-laws there's anti-tank
missiles and some low velocity
anti-aircraft missiles into our stocks
and there are more on the way of other
so and the second reason I'm not as
worried is you know the the big thing
that Putin respects and is is frightened
off is the NATO alliance that's 30
Nations so remember we are by our
strength and Alliance we are heart of an
alliance of that those 30 countries if
anyone attacks a NATO member we have a
mutual self-defense that's Article Five
off each other and that and that
ultimately gives us our power so we have
a coalition to help support us alongside
the fact we are starting to restock
okay are there any plan just to be clear
are there any plans to ramp up
production of ammunition and weapon
stocks because of the war in Ukraine
absolutely and those plans have been
made public for about six months we've
talked about them and we have either
negotiated with them and you know I
joined a deal a few months ago with uh
Sweden and Finland and Britain to
collectively buy more in-laws we've
started doing that I've visited the
factories and spoken to the leadership
of these countries uh companies sorry uh
either internationally trying to work
together or indeed individually so these
are not new plans they have been in
place some of the supply chains take
time to reheat and and you know I've
been very honest about that you know I
play with a pretty straight back about
those things to make sure that you know
that you can't just switch a button
because you've got to manage people's
expectations but we're definitely on the
job of that the you know prime minister
gave me an extra 500 million at the
budget to to start restocking the Autumn
statement sorry and so we're on the way
how would you describe your conversation
with the treasury over defense spending
are you confident of getting an increase
in defense spending but I've over the
years I've had many conversations with
the treasury and I you know the chance
for the Prime Minister indicated in the
Autumn statement something we all agree
with which is that you know defense
needs a greater proportion of spending
or greater amount of spending I think
the statement in Autumn was clear about
that in recognition about the the
growing Global insecurity and of course
I have a spending package that takes me
for another two years at the envelope
and and all I really in the position in
this moment is trying to negotiate
around uh you know those lessons we're
seeing from Ukraine and whether there
are any increased risks since our last
budget settlement and you know I'm not
going to carry that out in public but
I'm a I'm a sexual estate sexual states
often uh have discussions with treasury
whether you're the Department of Health
the Secretary of State or whether you're
the transport sector so of course we
have these conversations
okay Jen just finally
um defense secretary China is publicly
saying that it wants to be a peacemaker
uh between Russia and Ukraine
um but is it your understanding that
China is about to give weapons to Russia
well I've seen the reports in the media
and the United States observations and I
think I think you know it it it it can't
it can't help the peace if China
effectively supplies the one nation that
has broken the international law and the
sovereignty of Ukraine and been
inflicting war crimes that will not help
the peace but I'm also confident that
China is pretty clear that it wants this
to stop and you know we'll see the
details at 12 point pan I haven't
actually seen them yet but ultimately
China knows that Russia's Behavior has
been destabilizing you know what's been
interesting over the year is that a
country that is allegedly in Russia's
eyes a friend of it that China has been
abstaining at the U.N it hasn't voted
with Russia many times at all and I
think that's quite telling that if the
if you're if your big neighbor doesn't
actually vote actively in support of you
I think it's sending a strong message to
President Putin that this is an unwise
and a Folly that he's the decision that
he's gone down and that he should cease